run hey what's up guys it's Rob and
welcome to my tutorial for the spinning
windows today I'm going to show you how
to make the spinning windows which is a
really cool type of modular origami
model which as my subscribers know means
it's made up of a whole bunch of smaller
units or pieces would slide or fit into
one another just like we did with the
transforming ninja star so we're going
to need twelve pieces of square paper
once we have the twelve sheets we can
then go on to make six water bomb bases
and also six preliminary basis once
these are made we can combine them to
make the unit and then interlock the six
units to make the spinning windows so
let's get started for paper I'm going to
be using these sheets
however I'm going to show you how to
make four squares out of a piece of
letter size printer paper just like in
my other videos take the top edge fold
it across to the left side edge now you
can make a firm crease flip the paper
over and I like to fold the edge down
until you could see this edge here and
make another sharp crease along that
edge you can rip it off so now that we
have a square sheet we can fold it in
half this way and in half that way make
really good creases along the top and
now we can tear it into four and there
you go now you have four pieces of
square paper and all you need to do is
to do that for two more sheets so I'm
going to make the preliminary base right
now out of this piece of paper to do
that we're basically going to fold the
corner across to the opposite corner
make a crease
do the same with the other side so
corner to corner again and make another
crease and then we're going to open that
up you should see an X in the paper
we're going to fold the edge across to
the other edge and then do the same the
other way so take this edge and fold it
across that way okay so now we have a
tee and an X in the paper we're going to
fold the paper on one of the diagonal
folds like this then we're going to lift
up the first layer just like this and
we're going to tuck this corner down to
the bottom of the triangle right here so
tuck this corner in just like this and
then close these two flaps of the paper
do the same with the other side open
that push that corner in and then close
these two flaps and there you go that's
how to make the preliminary base so
that's done let's go ahead and make the
water bomb base it's basically the same
fold so let's go ahead and do that again
corner to corner opposite corner to
opposite corner unfold it you'll see the
X top edge to bottom edge open it up
right edge to left edge and then make
the crease now if you open it up you see
we have the same thing the T and the X
to make the water bomb base instead of
folding on the diagonal we're actually
folding on a horizontal like that edge
to edge then it's basically the same
kind of thing it's inside reverse fold
so you open up the edge of the paper
here and push this edge down just like
that and squeeze those two flaps
together do the same on the left side
open it up
push that in and close the flaps and
there you go now we have the preliminary
base and the water bomb base completed
all right guys so you got the hard part
out of the way which is basically just
the tedious job of making all of the
bases you should have six preliminary
bases and six water bomb bases so just
like I said before the preliminary base
and the water bomb base are going to be
joined together the preliminary base is
the one that's going to be on the
outside the water bomb base is the one
that's going to be on the inside so
we're going to fit the water bomb base
inside of the preliminary base and then
we're going to fold the corners of the
preliminary base inwards to interlock
them or combine them so whatever color
the preliminary base is is going to be
the color that shows take one of the
preliminary basis and just hold it with
the corners pointing towards you and as
you'll see we have these two corners
that are basically they look like little
V's and they're sticking in to the
center of the base take a waterbomb base
and you see we have the same thing here
here is the V that's basically sticking
inwards and we're going to fit this V of
the water bomb base into the V of the
preliminary base just like that and then
we're going to do the same with the
other side so just take this part and
just pop it right in between those two
flaps of the water bomb base just like
that all right so now they're seated in
one another and now you can close up the
preliminary base and hold it on the side
and just make sure that these edges are
aligned as you'll see mine aren't so
just kind of push down like that and
you'll see now it's seated properly all
we need to do now is to fold these
corners into the middle of the water
bomb base so just open it like this and
you'll see we want to fold this corner
right on top of the edge of the water
bomb base so just take it and fold it in
right there on the edge
and just make a crease don't make it too
sharp you'll see why later do the same
with the other corner so as before fold
it on the edge and give it a good crease
do the same with the other one and of
course give it a little fold do the same
with the last one fold it in on the edge
and give it a nice little so all you
need to do is to just collapse it again
just like that and there you go you've
made one of the units so let's go ahead
and make another one I'm gonna grab a
preliminary base going to grab a
waterbomb base again I'm going to hold
it with the points facing towards me
placing the blue waterbomb base inside
of the red preliminary base I make sure
that it's seated as well as possible I
then go ahead to squish it down and to
fold in all four corners of the
preliminary base inside the waterbomb
base then I squeeze the waterbomb base
and there's your second unit then
alright guys so you can go ahead and
make the rest of them I'm going to speed
up the video but I'll go ahead and make
them right now there's number three done
number four that's done
number five is done and number six is
completed now and there we go we have
all six units okay so now we're going to
interlock the six units and I'm not
going to lie it can be a little bit
frustrating and tricky so I'm going to
go through it slowly so that you guys
can kind of figure it out but a lot of
it you're going to have to try to figure
out yourself it's almost like a puzzle
we have to put the pieces together okay
what we will be doing is taking a look
at the unit and you'll notice that it
has a tip here and wrapped around the
tip we have these little pockets or
sleeves so we're basically going to be
joining each of the tips together so we
could take two different units okay and
what we're going to do is we're going to
slide one tip underneath into the other
tip just like this
and then we're going to align the edges
and you're going to try to slide the one
that's on top into the one that's on the
bottom just like that as you'll see it's
sliding in so then we're going to take
another one and now we have two free
tips here okay so we're going to take
another unit and we're going to join
these two tips with those two tips so
hold it here we're going to take one it
doesn't matter which you join you could
put this one on top or this one on top
so let's say I want to put this one on
top I would just slide the yellow one
into the other one there and then align
the edges and then try to slide that
underneath now if this isn't going in
what you need to do is you need to just
kind of grab the edges here and twist it
like this and that'll give you a little
opening like that so that you can take
the edge the corner and you can slide it
in like there right there okay so now we
have to join this tip to that one same
thing doesn't matter what you choose I'm
going to take the red one and I'm going
to put the yellow one into it and slide
the red underneath there as you'll see
it's not really going in so what I can
do is I can twist the yellow like that
and there you go now I opened it up a
little so right on the edge there you
could push and there you go now you'll
see we have a triangle you want to look
out for these triangles that's what
you're trying to design so we finished
three different pieces and I'm not going
to lie the last three pieces of the
trick is to get in because we have three
different colors I think it looks the
nicest if we put the opposite color so
the other blue piece opposite the
current blue piece so let's put it in
right over here
and again we're just going to take the
blue piece and we're going to slide and
just slide the blue tip in here and give
it a little bit of a tap okay so the
other blue piece goes in something like
that okay the red piece is going to go
over here to let you try to get the red
piece in it actually is easier if you
tap on it a little bit sometimes that'll
help you get the piece in so let's try
to get the yellow piece in now having a
little bit of difficulty and of course
if you can't slide it in you can lift
this up just a little bit but I kind of
twisting it what you could do if you're
really stuck is to unfold that corner
that you tucked into the water bomb base
slide the piece in and then you'll see
you're just going to have to retouch
that corner back underneath into the
water bomb base and that's another way
you can do it okay so as you'll see
these two need to get connected now so
let's try to get these two pieces in
I'll try to lift it up on the right side
and still having a little bit of
difficulty but what it looks like there
we go
all right so we just have four tips left
and one piece I also recommend that you
apply tape to each of the units where
they connected so that they don't pop
out when you're trying to put in the
last piece so we have one unit left and
we have to get it onto these four tips
of the other units it's going to look
just like this yellow unit when it's
done connected to four other pieces so
the thing is it's very tricky this is
the trickiest part so let's try with one
first and what I'm going to do just the
same thing we've been doing sliding it
into the other unit and there's one okay
I'm actually not going to tuck it in all
the way all right let's do the next one
next to it
okay there's two
a ch3
and for the last one
there it is okay so now we just have to
go back and make sure that the other
ones are tucked in all the way that's
really the hardest part alright guys so
once you've gotten everything tucked
into each other I know it's not that
easy but you will eventually get it it
might take 10 20 times but don't worry
about it you're gonna do it alright now
the best way to make this the spinning
windows spin is to kind of hold it one
in your palm like this the other one
gently with the other palm and you could
blow right in the corner here like this
or turn it that way either way it's
really cool it's a nice model you can
even hang it and let it blow in the wind
if you want to and as always thanks for
watching please leave a comment in the
comment section below and give it a
thumbs up if you enjoyed it I really
appreciate it and if you're not already
subscribed subscribe by clicking the
button I think it's down there now in
red if you haven't subscribed and it
should be silver if you are subscribed
until then I'll see you next time lilo
what is it with you in that couch I told
you I was going to make the spinning
windows today say bye bye